you were watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video
earlier this year I did a video titled
the truth about solar it highlighted
breakthroughs in solar technology over
recent months the video's conclusion
stated that in order for solar to be a
competitive form of energy generation
all the breakthrough is listed in the
video didn't even have to come to market
the fact that so many milestones were
occurring with increasing frequency
meant that solar could become viable
within the next decade in the past week
we've had yet another announcement in
the realms of solar technology by who
else but Elon Musk in a presentation to
the press he involved two things solar
roof tiles and an updated version of the
tesla powerwall
a battery that powers homes then he
showed off the solar-powered roof tiles
that eliminate the need for traditional
panels and a longer lasting home battery
which tesla calls the powerwall the
press had been absolutely loving this
and i've had a few people ask me to do a
video about this so i'll take a quick
look at both and share my thoughts let's
start with the solar roof tiles so what
are they here's the basic idea
instead of putting ugly solar panel
units on top of your roof to generate
power why not make the entire surface of
your roof generate power by making each
and every roof tile and miniature solar
panel the result would be fully
integrated and arguably better-looking
than a standard roof this soul energy
from the roof can be used immediately or
stored for use at night by using the
tesla powerwall so right off the bat i'm
going to say this slowly roof tiles are
nothing new they're actually called
solar shingles and have been around for
over a decade what's happening now is
just a phase shift in the technology
often what's needed for such technology
is a revolutionary kick someone to come
along and make it actually appealing to
the consumer think of it like the
electric car that technology had been
around for a hundred years but nobody
had gotten the product of the electric
car riot until the Tesla Model S came
around the Model S was a good performer
good-looking and
practical basically it was something
that people actually wanted now bring
that concept back to solar roofs and
Tesla and SolarCity want to do the same
thing so here's the basic pitch that was
set up the press-conference compared to
standard tiles these tiles look better a
better insulators last longer a more
durable and cost less when energy
savings are factored in okay so this all
sounds great but I really think we have
to wait for the technical details before
we can call this a real game-changer but
still the concept seems pretty sound in
terms of market scope there's about 80
to 100 million new roofs installed
globally every year so there's a huge
market for this kind of thing there's a
few cool things about the tiles firstly
they're designed to have a dual
appearance so from the ground they look
like normal tiles that is opaque but
from the perspective of the Sun they
look transparent allowing sunlight to
hit the integrated solar cell
second of all Elon has tweeted that the
panel's can keep themselves clean by
using heating elements much like the
real windshield of a car thirdly the
tiles actually much more durable
withstanding high force impacts that
should at least double the lifespan of
the tiles and comparison to normal roofs
according to musk and as a gas I doubt
we'll be thousands of wires connecting
each panel would make sense for each
panel to be connected by some kind of
clip-on system the fact that the solar
tiles look great is actually critical
for mainstream success if the roof
performed well but looked as dinky as
previous efforts from other companies
the adoption rate would be low with
Tesla it's no longer a choice between
style and being environmentally friendly
now both can be done simultaneously to
further this the push of the Tesla brand
is more likely to make for mainstream
adaptation all right so that's enough
about the roof now onto some stuff about
the tesla powerwall 2 compared to the
original power wall it has double the
energy storage at 14 kilowatt hours and
seven kilowatts of peak power musk
claims that you can power a four bedroom
house all day with one of these
and if you add in a solar roof you can
power that house indefinitely in
Australia where I live we've been taking
the solar battery storage thing fully on
board some housing construction
companies are already including the
power wall in newly built houses this
makes complete sense for our climate and
I'm sure other sunny countries will do
similar things in the future
so in conclusion basically the proposed
idea of these new roof tiles and battery
is to move a step closer to the
seamlessly fully integrated off-the-grid
house that looks great but with very
little hassle the aim is to make solar
attractive exciting and desirable now of
course these are the very early stages
in a long road to fully sustainable
housing and really this is the baby
phase of this technology the worst it
will ever be things will only get more
efficient cheaper and more viable as
time goes on I think in the grand scheme
of things with some really cool stuff so
anyway in summary that's a few of my
thoughts on the new Tesla roof and the
power wall tube if you want to know more
about the state of the art of solar or
more about the power wall I'll leave a
link to both of my videos on both of
those topics below thanks for watching
guys this has been - go go you've been
watching cold fusion give this video a
thumbs up if you liked it subscribe if
you just stumbled across this channel
and I'll see you again soon for the next
video
cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion it's me thinking
[Music]